seit den frühesten Tagen war die
Pressefreiheit das was Amerika ausmachte
Thomas Jefferson der an der
Unabhängigkeitserklärung mitschrieb
hielt freie Medien für eine freie Nation
für unverzichtbar und sagte wenn es mir
überlassen Liebe zu entscheiden ob wir
eine Regierung ohne Zeitungen oder
Zeitungen ohne eine Regierung haben
sollten würde ich keinen Augenblick
zögern das letztere vorzuziehen
das war im Jahr 1787 heute scheinen
unsere Zeitungen an Bedeutung zu
verlieren in einer multimedialen Welt
die weitgehend im Besitz und unter der
Kontrolle einer Handvoll großer
Medienkonzerne ist
wir sind wahrscheinlich die am stärksten
von den Medien beherrschte Gesellschaft
der Welt Jeff Cohen hat in den großen
Medien gearbeitet jetzt ist der einer
der schärfsten Kritiker der Branche ein
halbes Dutzend Unternehmen besitzt und
kontrolliert den größten Teil der
Mainstream-Medien in unserem Land wenn
man sich also ansieht wer Amerika
regiert oder wie Amerika gehört dann
sind es dieselben Leute die Amerika
propagieren
die Presse und die Medien die über
Nachrichten berichten oder Informationen
vermitteln sind nur ein kleiner Teil
eines riesigen Medien Imperium das
unterhaltungsprodukte herstellt die auch
eine auf Konsum basierende Lebensweise
verkaufen
wenn man sich ansieht während den
Vorständen der Medienkonzerne sitzt die
sitzen auch in den Vorständen der US
Ölkonzerne und der Militärunternehmen
wenn man also untersucht wie man Amerika
gehört dann sind das auch die Leute
denen die Medien gehören wir haben keine
staatlichen Medien aber in mancher
Hinsicht sind sie den staatlichen Medien
sehr ähnlich es ist halt der Start der
Unternehmen
wenn das wahr ist können wir sagen dass
die US-Medien nicht nur über Nachrichten
berichten wie wir sehen werden sind sie
nicht unabhängig vom System sondern
seine Stütze sie verstärken die
weltanschau und verteidigen die
Interessen derjenigen die Amerika
beherrschen
vor 30 Jahren beherrschten 50
Unternehmen die amerikanischen Medien
jetzt sind es nur noch Sex wir sind
einige Diagramme zum Medien besetzt die
diese Konzentration verdeutlichen mit
der zunehmenden Bedeutung neuer globaler
digitaler Unternehmen wie Google
Facebook und Twitter wurden die
US-amerikanischen Medien zu einer
transnationalen Kraft
die us-medienunternehmen befinden sich
zu einem großen Teil im Besitz von
Hedgefonds Investmentfonds und
Finanzunternehmen Barry james deik ist
ein Vermögensverwalter der sich mit
Medien Besitz beschäftigt hat die
Untersuchungen die ich durchgeführt habe
sind eindeutig ich bin sozusagen darüber
gestolpert die großen Medienunternehmen
die Disney ist die CBS die
nachrichtenkonzerne sie alle und das
sind alles öffentliche Dokumente sind
dem Besitz von
investmentfondsgesellschaften die
Mehrheit der Aktionäre ist im Besitz
solcher Gesellschaften sie beziehen also
auch einen Großteil ihrer Einnahmen von
diesen Unternehmen sie werden also nie
eine konsequente Kritik an ihnen hören
diese Unternehmen von den Medien
untersucht nein werden sie nicht sind
sie gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit in
irgendeiner Weise verantwortlich
rechenschaftspflichtig weiß die
Öffentlichkeit was sie tun die
Öffentlichkeit hat keine Ahnung sie
wissen nicht was sie tun er hat seine
Erkenntnisse in seinem Buch the pirates
of Manhattan dokumentiert
nicht erfahren
aber es gibt viel Berichterstattung vor
allem über Politik die oft wie ein Sport
Ereignis behandelt wird wobei der
Schwerpunkt auf Umfragewerten und
Wahlergebnissen liegt Mary Boyle
verfolgt die Berichterstattung über
Wahlen für kommen course wie sehen sie
die Rolle der Medien tragen Sie dazu bei
unsere Demokratie zu stärken oder tragen
Sie dazu bei uns zu spalten
das ist eine gute Frage ich glaube dass
hier mehrere Dinge vor sich gehen
offensichtlich gibt es eine Art von
Kabelkanälen die in verschiedenen Lagern
sind und sie zeigen keine verschiedenen
Standpunkte es gibt Fox News die die
Rechten zeigen MSNBC zeigt die Linke
bei einer solchen Konstellation schalten
die Amerikaner einfach den Sender ein
den sie hören wollen und der ihre
Ansichten vertritt
ohne dass sie eine Mischung aus
Meinungen Debatten oder ähnlichem
es wird weniger darüber berichtet was
vor sich geht
und ich glaube das betrifft vor allem
die Landes- und Kommunalpolitik wo noch
weniger über das politische Geschehen
berichtet wird
auch wenn die Welt für ihre Vielfalt
bekannt ist die US-Medien sind es nicht
in redaktioneller und ideologischer
Hinsicht neigt die Macht Elite dazu die
Ansichten der Regierung wiederzuspiegeln
Andersdenkende Politiker wie der
Kongressabgeordnete Jazz Jackson Junior
haben es schwer sich mit ihren Ansichten
gehört zu verschaffen wem gehören die
Medien wie wird das alles umgesetzt
einige der Mogule und titane der Medien
und der Industrie sind Teil des Problems
sie formen ein narrativ für das
amerikanische Volk eines das
letztendlich Millionen von Menschen dazu
bringt für Kandidaten zu stimmen die auf
dem narrativ basieren dass sie formen
basierend auf den Moderatoren die sie
kontrollieren und diese Amerikaner
neigen dazu auf der Grundlage dessen was
sie hören zu wählen und sich für das
System zu engagieren die Medien sind ein
wesentlicher Teil des Problems der
Historiker Eric Forner stimmt dem Zoo er
sagt es gebe hier nicht nur politische
Voreingenommenheit sondern auch das
worauf sich die Medien als Unternehmen
konzentrieren müssen um ein schaltquoten
und Einnahmen zu erzielen
irgendwie ist die Vorstellung von der
Macht die hinter den Menschen im Amt
steht in unseren Medien nicht sehr
präsent auch nicht wirklich in den
Köpfen der Menschen sie personalisieren
die Politik es gibt Persönlichkeiten die
sich gegenseitig bekämpfen aber sie
schauen nicht darauf wer hinter den
Kulissen steht
sie haben Recht dass die Medien sich auf
Persönlichkeiten konzentrieren und oft
sind es die Macken der Persönlichkeiten
Clintons sexuelle skip
aber vielleicht liegt es an der Natur
der Medien von heute dass sie sich auf
die schnellen Nachrichten konzentrieren
müssen das tiefgründige investigative
Berichterstattung nicht so sehr im
Vordergrund steht wie es vielleicht in
der Vergangenheit der Fall war man muss
Zeitungen verkaufen und Skandale
verkaufen Zeitungen Persönlichkeiten
verkaufen Zeitungen Prominenz verkauft
Zeitungen sie haben also recht dass die
größeren Zusammenhänge des Systems nicht
mehr so stark betont werden
es wird von vielen Leuten nicht mal
verstanden
es handelt sich um ein sehr großes Land
mit über 300 Millionen Einwohnern und
einem sehr komplizierten
wirtschaftlichen und politischen System
es ist schwierig genau zu verstehen wie
die Dinge funktionieren aber ich glaube
in gewissem Sinne ist die in diesem Land
weit verbreitete Anti regierungsstimmung
die im Allgemeinen mit dem rechten
Flügel in Verbindung gebracht wird auch
eine Reaktion auf das unbestimmte Gefühl
kein analytisches Gefühl aber das Gefühl
dass die Regierung unnahbar ist dass sie
nicht regiert dass sie die Menschen
nicht wirklich vertritt dass sie eine
sehr spezielle Interessen vertritt und
dieses Gefühl ist in diesem Land
ziemlich weit verbreitet
Medien beobachtungsgruppen sind auch
besorgt über die mangelnde Vielfalt in
den Medien wodurch sie nicht mehr
repräsentativ sind für das Land dem sie
dienen in Bezug auf Rasse und Geschlecht
das ungeschriebene Credo der New York
Times lautet verärgere nicht diejenigen
von denen wir in Bezug auf Geld und
Zugang abhängig sind
Patches war ein preisgekrönter
Journalist für die New York Times ein
amerikanischer Medienstar
s das sind also die Macht Elite und die
Finanziers die Werbung machen aber es
ist ausbaufähig ich meine man hat
zumindest in den Positionen in denen ich
war die Möglichkeit Journalismus zu
betreiben nicht dass es keine
Einschränkungen gäbe oder dass es keine
Bestrafungen gäbe
hätte es arbeitet nach wie vor sehr
geschätzt aber er ist der Meinung dass
ein Großteil der Presse letztlich eine
Phase ist die die Macht mehr deckt als
über sie zu berichten vor allem bei der
Berichterstattung über Wahlen
denn das politische Theater also diese
persönlichen Stories der Kandidaten das
ist alles irrelevant es ist
bedeutungslos und die Leute wir spielen
das Spiel spielen diese Scharade wir
spielen sie wenn wir gefügige
Konzernmedien haben wieso tun als sei
diese Scharade echt ich glaube das
Problem ist dass die Illusion immer noch
so stark ist die Menschen ändern sich
aber die Illusion ist immer noch so
mächtig dass die Leute verwechseln wo
die macht tatsächlich existiert
wie berichtet die New York Times über
die machzentren von denen viele sagen
dass sie Amerika beherrschen Chris
Berners ist Redakteur des New York Times
der täglich die Inhalte der Zeitung
überprüft seiner Meinung nach ist die
Zeitung zum Komplizen der Macht Elite
geworden
ist fast wie eine mini-nation und die
Korrespondenten die Verfasser von
meinungsbeiträgen die Redakteure sind
fast wie Diplomaten so wie Sie sich und
Ihre Selbstherrlichkeit darstellen so
wie sie mit anderen Politikern und
Diplomaten kommunizieren und sie sind
sehr einflussreich
würden Sie sagen dass Sie in Amerika
nicht nur Informationen sondern auch
Ideologien verbreiten
auf jeden Fall sie verbreiten eine ganz
bestimmte Ideologie denn ihre
laserschaft besteht hauptsächlich aus
Managern und Leuten die mehr als 90.000
Dollar im Jahr verdienen sie bedienen
also die Perspektive von Managern wenn
Sie also über Arbeitsbeziehungen
diskutieren haben sie oft eine
pro-management Sicht eine pro
business-sicht
wir probieren
Finanzjournalisten wie Stacy hörbert und
Max Kaiser fanden heraus dass viele
wirtschaftsfreundliche Berichte in
einigen Medien schlecht recherchiert
waren wie sie mir in einer Radiosendung
sagten
vom December 2019 im Dezember 2008 also
kurz nach dem Zusammenbruch von
berstörns und Lehman Brothers stürzten
die Märkte an einem Tag um 1.000 Punkte
ab und der Leiter von BBC World News
Business sagte wir hatten in einen
Vertrag über 10 Folgen er sagte glauben
Sie dass die Finanzkrise bis zum Ende
dieser 10 Folgen andauern wird
mit anderen Worten die Leute die für die
Planung der Berichterstattung zuständig
sind sind selbst sehr schlecht
informiert nun die Mainstream-Medien
sind selbst hoch verschuldet die
nachrichtenorganisationen sind zu
unterhaltungsunternehmen geworden und um
konkurrenzfähig zu sein nehmen Sie
enorme Schulden auf die Banker wollen
also ihre Gläubiger nicht beleidigen
weil sie ihnen die Kreditlinien kürzen
könnten sie sind in dieser Hinsicht
nicht unvoreingenommen beim besten
Willen nicht am spektakulärsten ist das
bei der New York Times zu beobachten
ihre Berichterstattung über die
Wallstreet ist der bärmlich
ein Grund warum die Presse
wirtschaftsfreundlich ist ist dass sie
selbst ein Unternehmen ist die Leute die
Medienunternehmen leiten zahlen sich
zunehmend selbst riesige Gehälter und
Boni so wie es auch Banker tun sagt
Barry dike
ich konnte es nicht glauben er hat 2009
59 Millionen Dollar verdient und er hat
wie neulich zu lesen war 2010 fast 70
Millionen Dollar verdient das ist der
Chef von
cbrs sie sagen dass sie alle ihre
Unternehmen so führen als wären sie
Banken
das ist ziemlich gut ein bankergehalt
ich meine 70 Millionen Dollar sind eine
Menge Geld und das bekommen sie bezahlt
die Medienunternehmen sind also Teil
dieses ganzen Systems wer regiert
Amerika
sie sind Teil dieser
ineinandergreifenden Beziehungen mit den
Finanzinstituten
daran besteht kein Zweifel da sind die
Medienunternehmen die riesig sind sie
sind Teil des Imperiums dann gibt es
natürlich die Banker da sind die großen
Gewerkschaften und da gibt es noch
weitere Faktoren aber die Medien gehören
definitiv dazu und die
Vermögensverwalter
genauso ist es die Konzerne denen die
US-Medien und das Fernsehen gehören sind
sehr wohlhabend und mächtig und die
Leute an der Spitze der
Nachrichtensender bekommen sehr viel
Geld ich habe nie auch nur annähernd so
viel Geld verdient wie in einem Jahr in
dem General Electric mein Chef bei MSNBC
war meiner Meinung nach findet also eine
selbst sensor-stadt bei der die Leute
die an die Spitze aufsteigen gelernt
haben wie sie keinen Ärger machen und
sie wissen dass sie ihre hohen Gehälter
verlieren wenn sie Ärger machen
Zeitungen wie die New York Times die
Washington Post und das Wallstreet
Journal neigen dazu ein narrativ zu
entwerfen dass uns sagt was wir für
wichtig halten sollen
sie geben die Agenda vor die auch die
Berichterstattung in den
Nachrichtensendungen beeinflusst sie
befassen sich nicht mit Ungleichheit und
Klassenunterschieden sagt der
unabhängige Medienmanager Brian Roli
sie sprechen nicht über die
Arbeiterklasse das liegt zum Teil auch
daran dass sie die Idee propagieren dass
man gewinnen kann wenn man einen
Lotterielos kauft also denkt man
wirklich dass man vielleicht gewinnen
könnte wenn du also zur Arbeit der
Klasse gehörst oder arbeitslos bist hast
du immer noch die Hoffnung dass du
irgendwie in die Mittelklasse aufsteigen
wirst
der Klasse an sich wird sehr wenig
Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt sie sagten dass
die Medien das nicht wirklich
diskutieren sie heben die
Klassenunterschiede in Amerika nicht
wirklich hervor sie sprechen viel lieber
überraschen Unterschiede oder ethnische
Unterschiede gleichzeitig sind sie sich
bei ihrem Geschäftspraktiken der
demografischen Entwicklung sehr bewusst
welche Bevölkerungsschicht sprechen Sie
an die Oberschicht wie Sie Ihre Werbung
gestalten wie Sie Ihr was verkaufen
können
ich meine das Internet ist ein perfektes
Beispiel dafür sie wissen schon alles wo
sie einen ständig in Scheiben schneiden
und zerlegen damit Sie genau wissen wie
viel man verdient und welches Produkt
Sie einem anbieten können das ist dieser
ganze Wahnsinn der Konsumgesellschaft
den der moderne Kapitalismus geschaffen
hat aber der springende Punkt auf den
sie hinaus wollen ist dass es zwar eine
klassenrealität gibt eine Arbeiterklasse
und eine herrschende Klasse oder eine
Bosch Asie aber die Menschen sind darauf
trainiert worden nicht in diesen
Begriffen zu denken so dass sie nicht
einmal wissen wer sie sind
einige Sender wie Fox News das Rupert
Mörder gehört scheinen sich mit der
Darstellung einer rechten politischen
Linie wohler zu füllen sie haben dazu
beigetragen dass viele Medien nach
rechts gerückt sind es gibt Leute die
sagen wir hätten den Bürgern von Bagdad
48 Stunden Zeit geben sollen den is zu
verlassen und Platz zu machen dann wäre
der Krieg schon vorbei das mag sein aber
die alten Medien werden von den neuen in
den Schatten gestellt sagt George
Vizepräsident von Digitals einem
Unternehmen das digitale Strategien für
große Unternehmen entwickelt und
untersucht wie wohlhabende Verbraucher
das Marketing bestimmen in einer Zeit
wachsender wirtschaftlicher Ungleichheit
es gibt eine Debatte darüber wie frei
das Internet wirklich ist angesichts der
Kontrolle durch Unternehmen und der
staatlichen Zensur aber es ermöglicht
mehr Interaktivität gleichzeitig dreht
sich die Aufmerksamkeit der Medien immer
noch um eine politische Elite mit
Autorität auch wenn diese Elite nicht
unbedingt die Macht hat Prioritäten zu
setzen oder politische Maßnahmen
durchzusetzen
aber wenn man mit normalen Amerikanern
spricht empfinden viele von ihnen das
als völlig fair sie sehen verschiedene
Standpunkte sie sehen Menschen die von
Zeit zu Zeit kritisch sind sie sehen die
Medien als die Liberalen Medien
ich war in der Sowjetunion und wir
wurden in diesem Land immer damit
aufgezogen dass das reine Propaganda ist
und ehrlich gesagt war das eine sehr
unwirksame Propaganda weil sie nie
Vorgaben zwei Standpunkte zu haben sie
vertraten immer nur einen Standpunkt und
sagten wie toll die Dinge sind aber in
unserem Land ist die Propaganda wirklich
effektiv weil sie den Anschein einer
Debatte erweckt
die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
werden nicht zulassen dass die
gefährlichsten Regime der Welt uns
bedrohen
Jeff Cohen sagt dass die Amerikaner vor
den Krieg über den Irak in die Irre
geführt wurden und heute über den Iran
in die Irre geführt werden er verwies
auf eine Studie über den Irak vor der
amerikanischen Invasion die zeigte dass
von etwa 393 Personen die von allen
Sendern befragt wurden nur drei gegen
den Krieg waren
denn fast alles was wir vor der Invasion
über den Irak wussten erwies sich als
falsch und fast alles was wir heute über
den Iran erfahren ist nicht korrekt vor
ein paar Monaten haben wir in der New
York Times gelesen dass die
Internationale Atomenergieorganisation
eine Einschätzung veröffentlicht hat
dass das iranische Atomprogramm ein
militärisches Ziel verfolgt und fair
diese medienkritische Gruppe ging zur
times und sagte welcher Bericht ist das
wir haben noch nie davon gehört die
Times wusste dass ihr ein großer Fehler
unterlaufen war es war ein bedeutender
Fehler sie entfernten den Satz von Ihrer
Website weigerten sich aber den Fehler
zu korrigieren
es sind nicht nur Kriege die propagiert
werden die Medien berichten nicht oft
über die Menschen hinter den Kulissen
die die Dinge leiten sagt William
Hartung der über den
militärischindustriellen Komplex
geschrieben hat
man sollte meinen dass der Journalismus
bei diesem Thema eine gewisse
Unabhängigkeit an den Tag legt aber in
einigen Fällen haben Reporter zu mir
gesagt naja wissen Sie ich kann das
Pentagon nicht härter angehen oder die
Unternehmen weil sie ein großer
Anzeigenkunde der Zeitung sind wir
werden unter Druck gesetzt wenn wir
solche Geschichten bringen wir berichten
also über den Krieg in Afghanistan wir
wiederholen was der Präsident zu
bestimmten Themen sagt und es gibt nicht
wirklich viele Interessen oder
Ressourcen um solche Verbindungen zu
untersuchen
Davidson der auch über Militärpolitik
schreibt stimmt dem Zug
die Konzernmedien sind mit dem
militärischindustriellen Komplex
verflochten einige Unternehmen machen
mit beiden Profite es gibt zwei große
politische Parteien die sich in dieser
Frage nicht sehr uneinig sind also steht
es nicht zu Debatte egal ob sich 90% der
Öffentlichkeit darüber aufregen es ist
keine akzeptable Nachricht
Maike Claire der die zerstörerische
Macht der Öl- und Gasunternehmen
untersucht hat sagt dass das gleiche
gilt wenn es um diese Industrie geht
die Medienberichten größtenteils nicht
darüber tatsächlich sind die Medien
aufgrund der Werbegelder die die Öl- und
gaslobby zur Verfügung stellt weitgehend
gleichgeschaltet sie sind in hohem Maße
von den Werbeeinnahmen abhängig und
daher sehr vorsichtig mit ihren Aussagen
das Großkapital ein wohlhabender und
häufiger Inserent in den Medien wird von
den Medien oft nicht kritisch beruhigt
das war auch während der Finanzkrise so
sagt Sheila Krummholz vom Center for
responsive politics
es sind komplizierte Themen von einem
guten Tag sind die Themen schwer zu
verstehen und sie scheinen dem
Durchschnitts Amerikaner sehr
undurchsichtig und unwichtig zu sein
es ist also möglich dass einige Medien
sich abgemüht haben zu erklären warum
das wichtige Informationen sind die die
Wähler brauchen
aber ich glaube dass die Medien einen
Großteil der Schuld am finanziellen
Zusammenbruch tragen letztendlich wissen
wir und das ist entscheidend wenn es ein
perfektes Szenario gibt das zeigt warum
Aufmerksamkeit so wichtig ist das
Hinterfragen der mächtigen Akteure und
was sie wollen und was Sie tun um ihren
Willen zu bekommen dann ist die
Finanzkrise das perfekte Beispiel
lässt zeigt uns wie wichtig Transparenz
ist
großer Reichtum erfordert große
Aufmerksamkeit
gemeinsam können wir Ihnen und Ihrem
Vermögen die Flügel verleihen um
aufzusteigen
[Musik]
Gruppensex wolfmanagement
gleichzeitig sind die Medien so
allgegenwärtig geworden online und
offline im Fernsehen und auf den Handys
das viele Amerikaner sagen sie sein
Opfer einer Informationsflut geworden je
mehr sie sehen desto weniger wissen Sie
[Musik]
die Informationsflut ist meiner Meinung
nach einer ernsthafte Bedrohung für die
Demokratie
denn sie funktioniert nicht wenn die
Menschen nicht wachsam sind
niemand wird die Mitglieder des
Kongresses für dich zur Rechenschaft
ziehen du musst sicherstellen dass du
gehört wirst
ich glaube es gibt auch das Gefühl dass
es Spannungen gibt manche würden sagen
eine gesunde Spannung zwischen der Sorge
um den Schutz des Prozesses der
Demokratie und der Regierung vor
ungewöhnlichem Einfluss des Geldes und
dem Schutz der Redefreiheit und der
Privatsphäre
niemand will Informationen zensieren wir
wollen dass unsere Vertreter über alle
Informationen verfügen auch wenn sie von
finanzstarken Unternehmen Gewerkschaften
oder handelsverbänden stammen also von
sehr eng gefassten Interessen wir wollen
nur sicherstellen dass Sie Ihre Aufgabe
nachkommen und nach alternativen
Perspektiven suchen doch wenn sie von
Gruppen kommen die keine Macht und kein
Geld haben
in der Medienkritik geht es in der Regel
darum worüber berichtet wird und worüber
nicht und nicht darum wie die
Erzählungen der Medien unser Denken
prägen das ist die Macht der Medien und
der Grund warum sie jetzt zu den Kräften
gehören die Amerika regieren
[Applaus]
jedes Schulkind lernt dass die Macht in
Washington Formel 3 geteilt ist
zwischen der Exekutive im Weißen Haus
das von Barack Obama besetzt ist
der Judikative an deren Spitze der
Oberste Gerichtshof mit neuen Richtern
steht die alle von der Politik ernannt
wurden und der Legislative in der der
Senat 100 Mitglieder hat davon zwei aus
jedem Bundesstaat und das
Repräsentantenhaus 435 die aus Bezirken
in ganz Amerika stammen dies ist das
formale System der gegenseitigen
Kontrolle dass das Land auf dem stabilen
Kurs der Demokratie halten soll
doch wo immer man in dieser Hauptstadt
Amerikas hingeht und mit den Menschen
zusammen trifft die am besten darüber
informiert sind wie die Regierung
wirklich funktioniert hört man dass das
System nicht funktioniert und dass die
Wähler nicht das Sagen haben wir hören
es von einem Mitglied des Kongresses wer
kontrolliert Amerika
eine elitäre Gruppe von Menschen die in
einer Stratosphäre auf der ganzen Welt
agieren jenseits der Verfassung jenseits
der Reichweite der Regierung sie
verfügen über enorme Ressourcen
wir hören es von einer Expertin für
Wahlen
unsere Politik wird gekapert sie wird
von Leuten gekapert die bereit sind
Millionen von Dollar auszugeben um
bestimmte Kandidaten zu wählen oder zu
besiegen wir hören es vom Leiter einer
öffentlichen Interessengruppe wir haben
eine unternehmensblutokratie die Regeln
in Washington werden von den Lobbyisten
geschrieben die im Namen der größten
Unternehmensinteressen im Lande arbeiten
und wir hören über Lobbyisten von einem
erfahrenen ehemaligen Mitarbeiter des
Kongresses der nur mit uns sprechen will
wenn sein Gesicht und seine Stimme
verfremdet werden
99 Prozent der Leute die ich im Kongress
als Lobbyisten sehe sind weiße Männer
und Frauen denen man ansieht dass sie
sehr schöne teure Anzüge Krawatten und
Kleider tragen und in die Büros der
Republikaner gehen ich sehe hier selten
Afroamerikaner ich sehe selten Hispano
Amerikaner oder Asiaten oder Muslime man
sieht diese sehr gut bekleideten Typen
die gerade aus einem Learjet gestiegen
sind und direkt aus dem Country Club
kommen und sie gehen in die Büros der
Republikaner und bitten um irgendeine
Steuersenkung
das sind nicht nur Meinungen dieses gut
recherchierte Buch von William downhoff
beschreibt detailliert wie die Regierung
heute von mächtigen elitären Kräften
außerhalb der Regierung geführt wird wie
wir sehen werden werden seine
Schlussfolgerungen von erfahrenen
Insidern hier in Washington DC
unterstützt
all diese insider sagen das Geld und
special interest jetzt die Kontrolle
haben
sie fragen sich wer regiert Amerika in
Washington sprachen wir mit führenden
Vertretern Dreier angesehener
Überwachungsorganisationen die sich auf
die Erforschung verborgener Kräfte
spezialisiert haben die hinter den
Kulissen wirken
public citizen konzentriert sich auf die
Themen Korruption und
Rechenschaftspflicht Robert Weissmann
ist ihr Präsident und beschrieb wie
Gesetze verabschiedet werden
wie entsteht ein Gesetzesentwurf wie
wird es zum Gesetz wie wird es umgesetzt
und wie wird es durchgesetzt bei jedem
Schritt auf dem Weg dorthin dominieren
die Konzerne der jeweiligen Branche den
Prozess
warum stellen die Kongressabgeordneten
die wir wählen dieses System nicht in
Frage
nun sie sind Produkte des Systems also
neigen sie dazu es zu begünstigen sie
haben mit diesem System Erfolg gehabt
und diejenigen die das System in Frage
stellen müssen gegen die etablierte
Machtkämpfen die Leute sind nach
Washington gekommen weil sie
herausgefunden haben wie sie das System
für sich nutzen können selbst wenn sie
als Insider gekommen sind werden sie
schnell darüber aufgeklärt wie die Dinge
hier laufen wenn sie hoffen etwas zu
erreichen also unterwerfen sie sich den
Interessen der Unternehmen
Instagram woher kommt das Geld die 100
größten Spender haben 77% des Geldes
gespendet das an superpacks geht das
heißt ein Prozent der Spender stellt 64%
des Geldes zur Verfügung es ist eine
winzige Elite die es sich leisten kann
die Beiträge zu leisten die in diesen
wahlzyklus am einflussreichsten sein
werden
diese Webseite open secrets.org
dokumentiert woher das ganze Geld in der
Politik stammt Sheila Krummholz leitet
sie als Geschäftsführerin des Center
Forrest ponsive politics
ich glaube viele der Menschen die sich
über die Rolle des Geldes in Washington
Sorgen machen und darüber wie es
privaten engstirnigen Interessen den Weg
ebnet glauben dass das Geld dass die
Mitglieder des Kongresses und die
politischen Entscheidungsträger die
Hebel der Macht kontrollieren
aber das die Spender die Gönner dieser
Leute die Fäden in der Hand haben
die Politiker sind sozusagen der
sichtbare Schauplatz der macht aber die
Leute die hinter ihnen stehen haben das
sagen
wie finden wir heraus wer diese Leute
sind
nun wir haben Millionen und
Abermillionen von Aufzeichnungen über
Spenden an Kandidaten an politische
Aktionskomitees einschließlich
lederchips-packs die eine Art
schmiergeldkasse sind die sie
kontrollieren und an Parteien wir können
auch sehen dass Geld direkt an die super
Packs geht das sind politische
aktionsausschüsse die eigentlich nur
Beiträge an Gruppen leisten sollen die
Geld für Dinge ausgeben die unabhängig
von Kampagnen und Parteien sind
das Problem ist dass es diesen geheimen
Geldtopf gibt der von Gruppen gefüllt
wird die nicht offenlegen woher das Geld
kommt
und sie schalten politische Werbung die
oft ziemlich vernichtend und Böse und
manchmal unverantwortlich ist aber sehr
einflussreich
und wir haben keine Ahnung woher das
Geld kommt
sie erklärte uns die Daten eine kleine
Minderheit kontrolliert den Prozess mit
sehr wenigen Millionären die die ganze
Politik finanzieren
es gibt 610 registriertes super Packs
195 von ihnen haben bisher das Geld für
die Werbung aufgebracht aber dieses
Diagramm zeigt wie dramatisch die
Ausgaben dieser Gruppen für Werbung
gestiegen sind
im Jahr 2012 haben wir Ausgaben von über
100 Millionen das sind 100% mehr als
2008 und 400% mehr als im letzten Zyklus
dies ist ein hohes huh der Lobbyisten in
Washington zwischen 1998 und 2012 die
US-Handelskammer gab 831 Millionen
Dollar aus
die American Medical Association 269
Millionen Dollar
General Electric 268 Millionen
Dollars of America geben zu mehr als 219
Millionen Dollar für Lobbyarbeit
ausgegeben zu haben und es gibt noch
viele viele mehr
das Jahr 2012 könnte ein Wendepunkt in
der amerikanischen Politik werden wegen
des vielen Geldes das buchstäblich
investiert wird Mary Boyle ist die
Vizepräsidentin von common course
wenn es darum geht wer Amerika regiert
muss man sich natürlich die Leute
ansehen die das meiste Geld für
politische Kampagnen Spenden es sind
sehr einflussreiche Leute die viel Geld
für politische Kampagnen Spenden
Millionen von Dollar und die etwas dafür
zurück haben wollen in der Regel handelt
es sich um sehr erfahrene Geschäftsleute
die viel Geld verdient haben weil sie
wissen was sie tun und sie tätigen keine
Investitionen ohne eine Gegenleistung zu
erwarten
das ist bedauerlich aber damit wird
Medien Zeit gekauft auch
Mailing-Aktionen werden damit gekauft
und natürlich werden damit auch
Kandidaten unterstützt die letztlich in
den US-Kongress einziehen und vielleicht
in ihrem Sinne abstimmen
die größten Geldgeber für politische
Kampagnen in Amerika sind die
Finanzinstitute die zweitgrößten Spender
sind die großen Bauträger das heißt dass
sie wenn sie für ein Amt kandidieren
gewählt werden müssen indem sie
versprechen eine Politik zu unterstützen
die vom Immobiliensektor unterstützt
wird und vom Finanzsektor der Kredite an
den Immobiliensektor gibt
die Demokratie dadurch nicht in Gefahr
ja
ich meine dank citizen United und einer
Reihe anderer Gerichtsurteile können
Unternehmen jetzt mehr Geld spenden als
es ihnen jemals zuvor erlaubt war und
das ist sicherlich eine Bedrohung für
unsere Demokratie denn dadurch werden
die Stimmen der normalen Menschen
übertönt es ist in gewisser Weise
entmutigend dass die Wahlen von 2008
gezeigt haben dass eine enorme Anzahl
von Menschen Veränderungen will und
dennoch scheint es auf Schritt und Tritt
Widerstand von Minderheiten zu geben die
sehr Geschick sind Veränderungen zu
unterminieren
sicherlich war 2008 die Wahl des Wandels
und wir waren enttäuscht dass aus dem
Weißen Haus nicht mehr Veränderung kam
nun der Präsident Obama sich zur
Wiederwahl stellt verbringt auch er die
meiste Zeit damit Geld zu beschaffen 2
Milliarden Dollar für politische
Kampagnen deshalb sagt Robert weiß man
dass dieser Skandal beide Parteien
betrifft ja das ist sicher ein
überparteiliches Problem die zwei
Milliarden Dollar beziehen sich nur auf
das Präsidentschaftsrennen das gesamte
nationale Rennen wird sich wohl auf 8
Milliarden belaufen Obama ist ein extrem
talentierter Spendensammler also wird er
viel Geld auftreiben können die riesigen
Summen die von Superreichen und
Unternehmen kommen werden aber wohl
überwiegend an die Republikaner gehen
es ist so teuer für ein Amt zu
kandidieren egal ob es sich um das
Präsidentenamt handelt oder die
Legislative eines Bundesstaates man muss
losziehen und Geld von Leuten sammeln
die eine Gegenleistung dafür wollen das
Geld in der Politik finanziert nicht nur
die Kandidaten es bezahlt die
Lobbyarbeit im Jahr 2011 gab es
12.654 Lobbyisten die 3,32 Milliarden
Dollar für die Beeinflussung von
Politikern Behörden und
regierungsstellenausgaben
letzte Woche war ich mit einer Gruppe
von 20 Frauen aus dem Nahen Osten
zusammen sie wollten etwas über Code
pink erfahren und ich sagte kommt zum
Kongress und lernt uns kennen wir
treffen uns in der Cafeteria und sahen
uns um und sagten all diese Leute
betreiben Lobbyarbeit im Kongress und
glauben dass sie Einfluss haben aber der
Einfluss findet nicht hier statt es gibt
einen besonderen Ort im Capitol wo die
Leute die Geld haben hingehen um
Lobbyarbeit zu betreiben sie haben auch
ihre speziellen Party bei denen Sie viel
Geld bezahlen um ihren Kongress
Abgeordneten persönlich zu treffen dort
werden die Dinge erledigt
laut der Wissenschaftlerin Francis Fox
pivin liegt das an einem anderen Problem
nicht alle Amerikaner können oder wollen
wählen
wir haben ein sehr entwickeltes sehr
verdrehtes und verzerrtes System derweil
Vertretung es ist nicht nur durch das
große Geld verzerrt obwohl das natürlich
sehr sehr wichtig ist weil es die
Werbung und den Wahlkampf ermöglicht
viele Menschen sind aber gar nicht
wahlberechtigt und selbst diejenigen die
Wellen sind nicht gerecht vertreten die
Menschen in kleineren Staaten sind
besser vertreten
das erklärt warum kleine aber gut
finanzierte Gruppen wie die Pro Israel
Lobby oder die promilitär Lobby so viel
Einfluss haben
untersucht wer Außenpolitik macht
es ist ein informelles Netzwerk von
Leuten die Amerika regieren auch wenn
sie nicht mit Schildern herumlaufen auf
denen steht wie regieren Amerika so sind
es doch diejenigen die die Politik
machen sei es mit Politikern sei es mit
Think Tanks sei es mit dem Militär sie
alle sind miteinander verbunden
wenn die sagt dass diese Lobbys eher
geeint als geteilt sind
es gibt zwar Meinungsverschiedenheiten
aber es geht dabei um Methoden nicht um
Ziele wissen sie so sind einige der
Meinung dass man einige Atomwaffen
schaffen sollte während andere meinen
dass man sie alle behalten sollte aber
die Unterschiede reichen wirklich von A
bis B wie man früher sagte
die tägliche Realität sieht so aus dass
diejenigen die hohe Positionen in der
Politik inne haben und starke
Verbindungen zu dem Geldinteressen und
die Geldinteressen selbst das Land
regieren
wir sind jetzt auf dem Weg zum Kongress
der in der Öffentlichkeit weniger als
10% Zustimmung genießt
wissen Sie woran sie einen
Kongressabgeordneten erkennen sie haben
hier eine kleine Anstecknadel und tragen
nie etwas bei sich das macht der
Assistent sie sehen lauter Leute die sie
anhimmeln leben in einer Blase sie
merken gar nicht dass das Land ihnen
gegenüber so zynisch ist
auch die Kongressabgeordneten sind
zynisch ich bin dem Abgeordneten John
kannias buchstäblich in einem dunklen
Gang begegnet er ist das dienstälteste
Mitglied und beklagt dass sie von
Lobbyisten überschwemmt werden
sehen sie dass viele Leute von der Wall
Street dem Kongress Spenden zukommen
lassen und versuchen Reformen zu
verhindern
ich meine der Kongress wollte die
Finanzgesetze reformieren und es sieht
so aus als ob sie auf regulatorischer
Ebene durch all diese Spenden von
Großbanken und der Wallstreet
aufgehalten werden
es wird sich zeigen in den
Quartalsberichten aber ich habe keinen
Grund zu glauben dass das aufgehört hat
oder reduziert wurde das Ergebnis ist
also dasselbe Stagnation
hat die Märkte mit einem handelsverlust
von über 2 Milliarden Dollar schockiert
zwei Wochen später wurde berichtet dass
die Großbank JP Morgan Chase beim zocken
mit exotischen derivatprodukten 2
Milliarden Dollar verloren hat
und das was sie ein synthetisches
Kreditportfolio nannten wenn Jamie
Diamond diesen Fehler macht denn wir
wissen dass er gut ist was zum Teufel
ist dann bei der City Group und der Bank
of America los die Fehler von JP Morgan
der gemessen an den Vermögenswerten
größten US-Bank haben die Finanzwelt
aufgeschreckt für viele werden
Erinnerungen an 2008 wach als die das
kannten Wetten der Großbanken das
Finanzsystem zum Einsturz zu bringen
drohten später wurde berichtet dass sich
die Lobbyisten der Bank gegen eine neue
Vorschrift gewehrt hatten deren
Verabschiedung diesen Riesen Verlust
verhindert hätte die schlechte Nachricht
machte im Internet die Runde
da es sich um den Derivate Markt handelt
ist die sehr wichtig es könnte sich als
nichts herausstellen die größte US-Bank
ist mit der US-Notenbank bestens
befreundet und natürlich geht es hier um
eine ganze Menge Schulden aber in keinem
der Kommentare die ich gesehen habe
wurde die Lobbyarbeit von JP Morgan
Chase erwähnt man sieht immer wieder wie
Banken in Probleme geraten ausrutschen
oder Amerikas größte Bank JP Morgan tut
genau das offen gesagt sind die Banken
ihr eigener schlimmster Feind
wir wissen dass wir schlampig und dumm
waren das ist ein schlechtes
Urteilsvermögen gab natürlich sollten
sich die Aufsichtsbehörden so etwas
ansehen wir sind bereit mit Ihnen
zusammenzuarbeiten wir werden die Sache
in Ordnung bringen daraus lernen und ein
besseres Unternehmen sein wenn es
abgeschlossen ist eine der
verblüffendsten Lehren aus all dem ist
dass die Unternehmen sich selbst nicht
unter Kontrolle haben so sehr dass sie
sogar ihre eigene Branche und ihre
eigenen Unternehmen zerstören das
kurzfristige Profitmotiv sichert in so
viele Poren von Einzelpersonen
Abteilungen Büros und ganzen Unternehmen
wir können Ihnen also definitiv nicht
zutrauen dass sie herausfinden wie sie
sich selbst kontrollieren können
spielte später eine Rolle beim Verbot
des Insiderhandels von Kongress
Mitgliedern mit Informationen die Sie
bei Anhörungen und Untersuchungen
erhalten
public citizen betrachtete das als
Korruption
der Gedanke dass die mächtigen nicht
eine Reihe von Regeln für sich selbst
aufstellen sollten aber eine Reihe von
Regeln für alle anderen wenn wir
erwarten dass das für unsere größten
Unternehmen und erfolgreichsten Bürger
gilt dann sollte es auch für unsere
gewählten Beamten gelten besonders in
einer Zeit in der es ein
vertrauensdefizit gibt zwischen dieser
Stadt und dem Rest des Landes
der Kongressabgeordnete Jazz Jackson
Junior Sohn des berühmten
Bürgerrechtlers vertritt seit 17 Jahren
einen Bezirk in Chicago
er hatte sich zur Aufgabe gemacht zu
untersuchen und zu erklären wie das
System historisch aufgebaut ist und den
Rechten der Staaten und besonderen
Interessen zu dienen
ich habe einen Antrag zur
Verfassungsänderung eingereicht um uns
das Recht auf eine öffentliche Bildung
von gleicher Qualität zu garantieren
weil jeder Amerikaner der eine
öffentliche Schule besucht nicht in das
Sklaverei der staatsrechte Leben sollte
die Lektion der Überwindung der
Verfassung durch die Afroamerikaner in
Bezug auf die Rechte der Bundesstaaten
wurde von den Amerikanern im Laufe der
Zeit nicht beherzigt und es ist genau
dieses System in dem sie heute
feststecken sie wissen es nur nicht wir
haben ihn gefragt warum der Kongress so
das funktional geworden ist
ich habe ihn noch nie so polarisiert
gesehen ich habe ihn noch nie so
gespalten gesehen entlang geographischer
Grenzen entlang Fraktionsgrenzen entlang
wirtschaftlicher und politischer Grenzen
das ist nicht das wofür die Demokratie
gedacht war es ist nicht das wozu sie
sich entwickeln sollte und leider ist
das amerikanische Volk das Opfer dieses
Prozesses
wie würden Sie die Frage beantworten wer
am Amerika regiert
es gibt zwei Arten von materieller macht
in diesem Land und in der Welt die eines
politisch und die andere wirtschaftlich
wir das Volk haben die politische Macht
das Wirtschaftssystem zu kontrollieren
und es gibt einen ständigen Kampf
zwischen der Macht des Volkes und der
wirtschaftlichen Macht wir das Volk
kontrollieren durch das politische
System unser wirtschaftliches Schicksal
und das der Nation die schwere Hand des
Wirtschaftssystems kontrolliert
zunehmend das politische System und
manipuliert das Volk
wer kontrolliert Amerika eine elitäre
Gruppe von Menschen die in einer
Stratosphäre weltweit und jenseits der
Verfassung agieren jenseits der reich
der Regierung sie verfügen über enorme
Ressourcen sie besitzen die Medien und
die Macht zu recherchieren sie können
das narrativ der Geschichten gestalten
sie können Kandidaten für öffentliche
ämterpositionieren und dem
amerikanischen Volk ein Bild vermitteln
das oft nicht der Realität entspricht
und doch sehen die Amerikaner dieses
Bild von einer Führungspersönlichkeit
und Stimmen für sie nur um später die
menschlichen Schwächen und
Unzulänglichkeiten der Person zu
entdecken
wir trafen uns mit einem ehemaligen
kongressmitarbeiter der zwölf Jahre lang
für einen führenden Abgeordneten
gearbeitet hat er wollte dass wir sein
Gesicht Schmerzen und seine Stimme
verzerren er beschrieb schonungslos wie
Entscheidungen getroffen werden
es ist eine großartige Institution aber
leider gibt es unzählige
Kongressabgeordnete die 60% ihrer Zeit
damit verbringen Geld zu beschaffen und
weil sie alle zwei Jahre kandidieren
müssen was keinen Sinn macht müssen sie
Millionen von Dollar aufbringen nur um
konkurrenzfähig zu sein um ins Fernsehen
zu kommen denn CBS ABC NBC und CNN
verlangen unverschämt viel Geld für
Fernsehwerbung
es sollte kostenlos oder sehr
kostengünstig sein so kommt es dass
diese Kongressmitglieder sich auf
gutwillige Mitarbeiter verlassen viele
von ihnen kommen gerade aus dem College
viele von ihnen waren Praktikanten die
wichtige Entscheidungen in den Bereichen
außen und Innenpolitik Gesundheitswesen
Beschäftigung und Arbeitsplätze treffen
sollten aber sie sind noch nicht
wirklich reif genug
er sagte uns auch dass viele der
Mitarbeiter von Interessen Eltern und
Großspendern gekauft werden
viele dieser jungen Leute kommen gerade
aus dem College oder von der Uni sie
müssen diese enormen Kredite an das
College und die Uni zurückzahlen sie
zahlen unglaubliche mieten in Washington
DC und Nord Virginia oft mehr als ein
Drittel ihres Einkommens viele von ihnen
werden von Arbeitslosen
Familienmitgliedern betreut sie stehen
also unter dem Druck für die Geldgeber
in der Case Street zu arbeiten viele
Mitarbeiter auch fortschrittliche
Mitarbeiter haben das Parlament
verlassen um für die großen
Pharmakonzerne oder Ölgesellschaften zu
arbeiten
in der Regel sind es die größten
Unternehmen der jeweiligen Branche die
man sich anschaut wenn es um die gesamte
nationale Wirtschaftspolitik geht ist
die Wall Street der dominierende
Einfluss ich weiß nicht wie es in der
Pharmaindustrie aussieht dort haben die
großen Pharmakonzerne das sagen in der
Finanzindustrie sind es immer noch die
größten Institutionen die die
Tagesordnung bestimmen
es gab Umfragen was der Amerikaner
glauben wohin das Geld in unserer
Regierung fließt und so gut wie niemand
hat eine Ahnung die Menschen
überschätzen bei weitem wie viel in die
Entwicklungshilfe fließt das liegt zum
Teil daran dass wir die Bewaffnung
fremder Nationen als Hilfe bezeichnen
und sie unterschätzen wie viel für das
Militär ausgegeben wird und doch sagt
unser Informant ein ehemaliger
Mitarbeiter des Kongresses ist das wahre
Problem nicht nur die Macht der
Unternehmen das größte Problem in
Amerika sind nicht die Konzerne es ist
nicht mal unbedingt das Geld für die
Wahlkämpfe das größte Problem ist dass
die Amerikaner sich nicht wirklich in
ihren kongressbezirken organisieren um
die Macht der Special Interest zu
mindern sie machen keinen Gebrauch von
der Demokratie weil sie nicht wissen wie
das Spiel funktioniert die Spender
wissen genau wie das Spiel funktioniert
wenn man eine Mitglied des Kongresses
Geld gibt würde wahrscheinlich das tun
worum er gebeten wurde wenn man also
Millionen und Abermillionen von Menschen
hat die für Obama oder für ihren
Kongress Abgeordneten gestimmt haben
dann ist das das Ende ihres politischen
Engagements dann ist das das Ende der
Demokratie
in keiner Serie darüber wer Amerika
regiert darf der Einfluss der Wall
Street auf die Finanzwelt fehlen wir
haben dessen Einfluss bis zum Schluss
aufgespart wohlwissend dass dieser
Finanzdistrikt im heutigen Amerika ein
zentrales Machtzentrum ist eine
Drehscheibe für die Finanzialisierung
einer Wirtschaft in der die Kontrolle
des großen Geldes zentral ist für die
Kontrolle von Politik und Gesellschaft
wir haben mit einem angesehenen
Unternehmensleiter gesprochen der uns
klipp und klar sagte dass die reichen
heute Amerika regieren meine persönliche
Meinung ist dass ein großer Teil der
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung auf die
Globalisierung und Digitalisierung der
Wirtschaft zurückzuführen ist das lässt
sich nicht aufhalten
Professor Stanley ironowitz zitiert den
berühmten Soziologen seawrite Mills zum
gleichen Thema vor 50 Jahren
der Kraft des Unternehmens Kapitals und
sie war schon Mitte der 50er Jahre
natürlich ist sie heute viel stärker
akzentuiert weil die Industriekonzerne
relativ zurückgegangen sind
ich habe Dinge gehört die sie umhauen
werden und ich denke es ist jetzt an der
Zeit dass sie die ganze Geschichte
erfahren viele Amerikaner sehen all das
als eine Verschwörung einer nicht
rechenschaftspflichtigen geheimen Kabale
wie wie ein Machtzentrum jenseits der
demokratischen Kontrolle agiert das
Internet ist voll von Videos über
Milliardäre und ihre komplette die alles
kontrollieren
es passiert genau jetzt es handelt sich
um eine Verschwörung der
institutionellen Korruption auf höchster
Ebene
von den internationalen Bänkern bis zu
den Superreichen von Washington bis Rom
sie alle stecken unter einer Decke ist
die Wallstreet eine Verschwörung welche
Rolle spielt sie bei der Frage wer
Amerika regiert ist es seinen Job von
außen oder von innen
es geht nicht um Eliten außerhalb des
Staates obwohl sie natürlich enormen
Einfluss haben aber der Grund warum sie
enormen Einfluss haben ist dass der
Staat so strukturiert ist dass sie ihre
Macht und Autorität in der Gesellschaft
reproduziert hier muss sein leo panage
ist Wirtschaftswissenschaftler und
Analytiker und ich glaube er hat eine
Perspektive aufgezeigt die wir bisher
noch nicht gehört haben
er kämpft gegen die verschwörerische
Vorstellung dass eine kleine Gruppe von
Menschen irgendwo in einem Raum die
Dinge steuert er spricht über die
Struktur der Gesellschaft ihre Werte und
darüber wer wirklich das Sagen hat
die Wall Street ist eine Industrie mit
tausenden von miteinander verbundenen
Unternehmen die sich selbst als
Finanzdienstleistungsbranche bezeichnen
aber sie sind viel mehr als das sie
haben großen Einfluss darauf wie unser
Land geführt wird sagt Robert Weissmann
der Leiter der öffentlichen
Interessengruppe public citizen man kann
nicht verstehen was in den 38 Jahren in
Bezug auf die Wirtschaftspolitik
passiert ist und wie sich das Land
politisch entwickelt hat ohne zu
verstehen wie die Wall Street an Macht
gewonnen hat sie hat an wirtschaftlicher
und politischer Macht gewonnen und das
hat zu Synergieeffekten geführt sie
nutzen ihre politische Macht um
Vorschriften auszuhebeln
früher kauften Anleger Aktien von
Unternehmen und Branchen die
Arbeitsplätze schufen
Dienstleistungen erbrachten oder
wertvolle Produkte herstellten diese
Zeiten sind vorbei sie machten einen
immer größeren Teil der Wirtschaft aus
dann gingen wir von einer Wirtschaft der
Produktion zu einer Wirtschaft über die
auf Konsum den Kauf und Verkauf von
Dingen basiert bald machten die
Verbraucher 70 Prozent der Wirtschaft
aus
immer größer wurden
je größer ihr Anteil an der Wirtschaft
wurde desto mehr politische Macht
konnten sie ausüben in einem für das
Funktionieren der Demokratie wirklich
schrecklichen Kreislauf das führte zum
Crash 2008 die Verbraucher verschuldeten
sich immer mehr
und die Bänker kauften und verkauften
Schulden während sie die Regeln für ihre
Aktivitäten ändern
eine ganze Reihe von der
Regulierungsmaßnahmen die durch den
politischen Einfluss der Wall Street
ermöglicht wurden führten dazu dass das
funktionierende Wirtschaft zur
Katastrophe wurde
denn wie mit der Milliardär und Investor
George Soros vor Jahren sagte ist die
kapitalistische Wirtschaft von Natur aus
instabil und anfällig für blasen und
Zusammenbrüche
ich gehe von der Theorie aus das die
Finanzmärkte von Natur aus instabil sind
um Exzesse zu verhindern braucht man
eine Art von Intervention
Überwachung Regulierung leider ist die
vorherrschende Vorstellung dass die
Märkte zum Gleichgewicht tendieren
und so arbeiten wir mit einer falschen
Vorstellung davon wie Finanzmärkte
funktionieren
jemand hat uns zum Beispiel gesagt dass
das Schöne an der Globalisierung ist
dass niemand die Kontrolle hat
das ist ein großer Vorteil denn
Kontrollen haben ihre eigenen Probleme
tatsächlich sind merkte viel effizienter
als zentralisierte Kontrollen aber das
bedeutet nicht dass es absolut keine
Kontrolle geben sollte
und wenn man sich die Realität anschaut
dann hat es seit es den Kapitalismus und
die Finanzmärkte gibt immer wieder
Krisen gegeben und jedes Mal wenn es
eine Krise gab wurde etwas unternommen
um eine Wiederholung zu verhindern
das Problem dieses Mal ist der
dramatische Anstieg der Schulden sehen
Sie hier das sind Diagramme die die
Verschuldung der USA zeigen Seite für
Seite die zeigen wie viel Geld
geschuldet wird es ist verblüffend
noch komplizierter wird es wenn man über
neue Finanzinstrumente wie dieivate
spricht die die Branche in ein globales
Casino verwandelt haben
Derivate können auch als Versicherung
eingesetzt werden indem man darauf
wettet dass ein Kredit vor einem
bestimmten Datum ausfällt oder nicht sie
werden zur Grundlage eines großen
wettsystems wie in einem Casino
der finanzjournalist Max Kaiser sagt
dass nur eine Handvoll großer
Finanzunternehmen die Branche und die
Weltwirtschaft beherrschen
zweifellos JP Morgan steckt mit der Fett
unter einer Decke es ist ein
zentralbankensystem die Wallstreet
wettet auf zukünftige Werte und die
Entwicklung von praktisch allem was
wertvoll ist
morgen und Goldman Sex sind die beiden
Hauptakteuren dieser globalen Finanzwelt
bald wurden CEOs finanziert und
Führungskräfte einer kleinen Anzahl von
Investmentbanken und Hedgefonds reich
und mächtig indem sie spezialisierte
Märkte mit hohen Einsätzen
kontrollierten sie sind mit dem
zentralbanksystem verbunden also mit der
Fett der EZB die Bank für
internationalen Zahlungsausgleich in der
Schweiz ist sowas wie die Zentralbank
der Zentralbanken ihr Hauptzweck ist es
die Zinssätze so nah wie möglich bei
Null zu halten damit die Leute die sich
Geld zum Spekulieren leihen ähnlich wie
möglich spekulieren können ohne für das
Geld dass sie sich zum Spekulieren
leihen bezahlen zu müssen auch wenn
diese Finanzmärkte angeblich für alle
offen sind haben einige wenige Händler
Investoren und Vermögensverwalter die
Märkte so strukturiert dass sie ihren
eigenen Reichtum und ihre Macht
vergrößern können
wenn Sie einmal eine schlechte Wetter
eingehen versuchen Sie schnell sie mit
Sparprogrammen oder eine Art
Rettungsprogramm oder einem Programm zur
quantitativen Lockerung zu decken
eine Schweizer Studie von Physikern über
die Eigentumsverhältnisse und die
Kontrolle von Börsen in 48 Ländern
untersuchte
24.877 Aktien und
106.41 Aktien Inhaber
zu ihrem Erstaunen stellten sie fest
dass nur zehn Unternehmen den gesamten
Aktien besetzt dominieren hier sind sie
wenn wir über Geld und ihr Wall Street
sprechen müssen wir uns die Frage
stellen woher das Geld kommt mit dem auf
unseren Finanzmärkten spekuliert wird
dieser Mann weiß es Barry James Dyke er
ist Vermögensverwalter und arbeitet mit
Kunden woher kommt das also
das Geld kommt aus Ersparnissen den
rentenforst der Leute die für den
Ruhestand sparen aber wissen die Leute
die Geld auf diese Kunden einzahlen wie
es ausgegeben wird
sie haben nicht die geringste Ahnung
erst jetzt als Folge der Finanzkrise
erfährt die Öffentlichkeit langsam dass
die selbst ernannten Herren des
Universums an der Wall Street mit
riskanten Investitionen spekuliert und
einen Crash verursacht haben
der Herausgeber von Vanity Fair schrieb
man könne mit Fug und Recht behaupten
dass sich die Kette katastrophaler
wecken die einige hundert Banker im
letzten Jahrzehnt abgeschlossen haben
als das größte gewaltlose Verbrechen
gegen die Menschheit in der Geschichte
herausstellen könnte
sie haben die Weltwirtschaft in die Knie
gezwungen Dutzende von Millionen
Menschen um ihren Arbeitsplatz und ihr
zu Hause gebracht und die Altersvorsorge
einer ganzen Generation zu nicht gemacht
und sie könnten schätzungsweise 200
Millionen Menschen weltweit in bittere
Armut treiben
im Jahr 2010 vor Occupy Wall Street
demonstrierten die Gewerkschaften gegen
die Verbrechen der Wallstreet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am 29 April findet ein Marsch auf die
Wall Street statt der von der aflcio
organisiert wird die nach eigenen
Angaben bisher 200 Proteste organisiert
hat was man aber aufgrund der
Medienberichterstattung nicht weiß
nun heute sind die Medien draußen und
sie marschieren wegen eines Diebstahls
Millionen von Arbeitsplätzen sind
verschwunden laut LfL CIO 11 Millionen
sie wollen Rache sie wollen die Wall
Street zur Kasse bitten sie wollen eine
neue Steuer auf Finanztransaktionen
[Musik]
wir versuchen uns von einer Finanzkrise
zu erholen von der manche sagen sie sei
noch schlimmer als die Depression in den
dreißiger Jahren und dennoch werden die
vorgeschlagenen Reformen die sehr
bescheiden sind von den Wallstreet
Firmen und Finanziers auf
regulatorischer Ebene mit Händen und
Füßen bekämpft
glauben Sie dass Sie einen
unverhältnismäßig großen Einfluss auf
den Kongress haben
gibt es keinen Zweifel nicht nur auf den
Kongress sondern auch auf die Parlamente
der Bundesstaaten ihre Macht zieht sich
durch das gesamte amerikanische
politische System
ich habe gelesen dass die
Finanzdienstleistungsbranche 28
Lobbyisten pro kongressmitglied
eingestellt hat um zu versuchen deren
Entscheidungen zu beeinflussen was
passiert mit ihnen wenn Lobbyisten in
ihr Büro kommen und versuchen sie dazu
zu bringen in ihrem Sinne zu stimmen wie
funktioniert das
ist sehr schwer einen Termin bei mir zu
bekommen ich glaube nicht dass sie viel
Geld ausgegeben um mich zu beeinflussen
ich bin mir über meine Auffassung von
einer repräsentativen Regierung im
klaren und von der Verfassung mein
Bezirk ist zwar konkurrenzfähig aber es
gibt noch viel mehr konkurrenzfähige
Bezirke als meinen und jedes
kongressmitglied wird in diesem Maße zum
Gefangenen des Wahlprozesses und des
Prozesses der
mittelbeschaffungholz vom Center for
responsive sagt die Macht der Wall
Street seit gut dokumentiert
Wall Street the banks in the Wall Street
die Banken und die Finanzindustrie im
Allgemeinen sind die größte einzelquelle
für Wahlkampfgelder in den USA und das
schon seit Jahren wenn nicht Jahrzehnten
man geht dorthin wo das Geld ist sie
haben nicht nur politische
Aktionskomitees die einflussreichen
Kongress Mitgliedern die für ihre
Branche zuständig sind Höchstbeträge
zukommen lassen können sondern Sie
können auch Hunderttausende von Dollar
allein unter ihren Partnern und
Vizepräsidenten und Führungskräften in
ihren Unternehmen auftreiben
sie sagt dass ihr Einfluss die Wahl 2012
beeinflussen wird
sie können eine Menge Geld auftreiben
und das zeigt sich auch ganz konkret im
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf 2012 womit
Romney aus der private equity-branche
kommt und Barack Obama davor der
Liebling der Wall Street war
die Wall Street und insbesondere die
Banken sind also ein enorm
einflussreicher Teil der US- Industrie
diese Macht wird deutlich wenn
Lobbyisten der Wall Street versuchen die
vom Kongress verabschiedeten
finanzreformen zu sabotieren
tun die Regulierungsbehörden nach der
Verabschiedung eines Gesetzes das was
der Kongress ihnen aufgetragen hat im
Großen und Ganzen nein sie sind mit dem
Erlass der Vorschriften weit in Verzug
dort wo sie Regeln erlassen haben werden
sie fast immer von der Handelskammer dem
financial Securitys roundable oder
anderen Wall Street Interessen vor
Gericht angefochten mit einer Justiz die
dem Großkapital wohlgesonnen ist haben
sie es schwer die von ihnen erlassenen
Regeln aufrecht zu erhalten
Reformen können also verabschiedet aber
auch sortiert werden
ja sie bekommen mehrere Bisse in den
Apfel einen im Kongress wo sie enorme
Macht haben aber zumindest ist es meist
ein öffentlicher Kampf und dann gehen
Sie zu den Regulierungsbehörden wo es
unter dem Radar passiert es gibt keine
öffentliche Kontrolle kürzlich
diskutierte ich in einer Radiosendung
mit den Finanzjournalisten Max Kaiser
und Stacy Herbert über die Macht der
Wall Street und den finanziellen
Zusammenbruch so wie mit Andys
Tierschützer der eine Kampagne gegen ein
Unternehmen führte das schmerzhafte
medizinische Tests an Welten durchführt
nachdem seine Gruppe den Aktienkurs in
den Keller getrieben hatte ging das
Unternehmen pleite aber dann bezeichnete
ihn die Regierung als finanzterroristen
und schickte ihn ins Gefängnis
zu Beginn haben wir die Wall Street mit
der Titanic verglichen dem unsinkbaren
Schiff das gesunken ist
wäre die Titanic die Geschichte von
heute wäre der Unterschied das Goldman
Sachs und JP Morgan schwere Wetten
darauf eingegangen wären dass das Schiff
sinkt und hängt Paulsen wäre dort unten
um den Rest zu vergrößern
das bringt mich zu einer neuen Studie
die erst kürzlich veröffentlicht wurde
und in der hunderte von Schiffswracks
der letzten paar hundert Jahre
untersucht wurden sie fanden heraus dass
Frauen und Kinder in der Regel häufiger
sterben als Männer und dass der Kapitän
normalerweise nicht mit dem Schiff
untergeht bei ihnen war die
Überlebensrate in der Regel am höchsten
diese Leute verwenden Derivate Warren
Buffett nennt sie finanzielle Massen
Vernichtungswaffen um die Situation zu
verschlimmern weil sich ihre Wetten
darauf dass diese Katastrophen schlimmer
werden enorm auszahlen das sehen wir in
den Zahlen an den Boni darin spiegelt es
sich wieder
vorhin genickt als Max überall das
gesprochen hat
stimmt es wirklich dass sie
gewissermaßen gegen uns wetten dass sie
hoffen dass schlimme Dinge passieren
ich glaube nicht dass jeder an der Wall
Street diese Mentalität hat aber es gibt
eine Kultur in der die Leute gelernt
haben ein Verhalten zumindest zu
akzeptieren wie zum Beispiel diese
Investitionen die Wetten gegen das
Scheitern von Dingen sei es eine
Regierung ein Land oder ein Unternehmen
und zu sagen oh gut ich kann das
rechtfertigen und man betrachtet das wie
Zahlen man schaut nicht auf die Menschen
die dahinter stehen man schaut nicht auf
die Familien die darunter leiden auf das
Land das darunter leidet
worden
was mich verblüfft ist die Tatsache dass
sie ein Bild der Absicht zeichnen dass
die Menschen Dinge taten um ihre eigenen
Interessen zu fördern sie wussten was
sie taten es war kalkuliert und doch
scheint es in den meisten Medien so als
ob es eine Art Fehler ist
mehlkalkulation dargestellt wird
wir wollten ja dass der Immobilienmarkt
steigt aber ist gesunken man kann uns
nicht die Schuld geben jeder hat es
getan also hat es keiner getan also kann
auch niemand belangt werden wenn es eine
Absicht gab ist das gut oder schlecht
manche sagen es ist gut dass es in einer
Wirtschaft Menschen gibt die Parasiten
sind denn sie sind nützlich ich habe
Parasiten in meine Damen sie erfüllen
eine wichtige Funktion das Problem ist
dass Parasiten nicht mein Herz meine
Lunge und mein Gehirn kontrollieren in
Amerika schreiben die Parasiten die
Regeln die eigentlich sie kontrollieren
sollten also haben sie das Sagen
beeinflusst die Wall Street das Kapital
unsere Politik nun sie werden zu
politischen Entscheidungsträgern
zumindest für kurze Zeit und kehren dann
wieder zu den Banken zurück
es ist also eine Art Drehtür es sein
schwer im Wesentlichen oder Obama die
Positionen im Kabinett die das
Finanzwesen Regeln werden von früheren
Banken Geschäfts besetzt oder sie kehren
vielleicht als Ehrenvorsitzende in den
Vorstand zurück es ist diese inzestulse
Beziehung zwischen der Wallstreet und
dem politischen Entscheidungsträgern das
klingt so korrupt
Danny sie fragen wer Amerika regiert und
ich sage es ist die Unwissenheit Thomas
Jefferson hat gewarnt dass wir Medien
brauchen die die Bevölkerung informieren
sonst verlieren wir unsere Demokratie es
ist die Unwissenheit die uns
aufgezwungen wird die das Wissen
kriminalisiert
das ist etwas worüber ich erschrocken
war als die Netzwerk am Times Square
eröffnete ein großes Studium mit einem
großen Fenster vor der Tür und ich sagte
ich würde gerne die Börse besichtigen
das war zu der Zeit als Bernie Madoff
die Nester gleitete
und sie sagten sie können die Börse
nicht besichtigen es gibt keine es sieht
aus wie eine Börse es gibt ein Gebäude
auf dem nestext steht aber der
eigentliche Betrieb sind Computer
der algorithmische Handel geht weiter
rüber hinaus es geht nicht um
Einzelpersonen die ein Risiko eingehen
um einen Markt als Teil eines
kapitalistischen Systems zu schaffen es
sind Computer die über einen praktisch
unbegrenzten kreditverfügen da die
Kreditkosten jetzt bei Null liegen eine
Bank wie JP Morgan mit einer 90
Millionen Dollar Bilanz an Derivaten
kann einem Computerprogramm eine Billion
Dollar leihen um eine Wette
abzuschließen wenn sie nicht aufgeht
gibt es eine staatliche Rettungsaktion
wenn sie aufgeht bekommen sie einen
Bonus das geht schon seit Jahren so aber
es ist noch unverhältnismäßiger und
asymmetrischer geworden
diese Verlagerung hin zu super schnellen
Computern ist nur ein weiteres Beispiel
für die tiefgreifende Machtverschiebung
die Finanzwelt übernimmt faktisch die
Macht und die Politiker umwerben die
wallstreets auf globalen Konferenzen und
bei privaten Treffen die George Soros
erklärt
das ist eigentlich symptomatisch für das
Zeitalter in dem Präsidenten und
Premierminister die Finanziers und
industriellen umwerben den das schön ist
es zeigt eine Verschiebung der relativen
Machtverhältnisse relativ
Bauer aber ich glaube nicht dass die
Wirtschaft in irgendeiner Weise die
Macht des Staates ersetzen kann denn es
ist eine andere Art von macht die
Souveränität liegt also immer noch in
den Händen des Staates
es klingt wie eine Verschwörungstheorie
aber die Wall Street kontrolliert alles
sie sind die Hauptaktionäre aller großen
Unternehmen sehen Sie sich die BiPi
Ölpest an der größte Aktionärs JP Morgan
es passiert gerade so viel was jetzt
passiert ist nicht mehr aufzuhalten
jeder weiß dass das System kaputt ist
egal ob man zu dem einen Prozent oder
den 99% gehört ein Republikaner ist ein
Demokrat ein Anarchist Kommunist
Kapitalist jeder weiß dass das System
kaputt ist also müssen wir es jetzt
reparieren
das letzte Wort hat ein Wissenschaftler
mit Weitblick
der Historiker Eric fona
wir haben es mit einem ernsthaften
Demokratie definitiv zu tun nicht nur in
den USA sondern auch in vielen anderen
Ländern ich will nicht ganz sagen dass
eine Plutokratie alles bestimmt was in
den USA geschieht aber ich glaube dass
Demokratiedefizit ergibt sich aus der
Tatsache dass grundsätzliche Fragen von
der Demokratie ausgeschlossen sind es
spielt keine Rolle wer gewählt wird bei
den grundlegenden Fragen der Finanzen
der die Industrialisierung und
dergleichen geht es um die
Globalisierung um den Verlust der Macht
der einfachen Leute über ihr eigenes
Leben das steht nicht zur Diskussion es
ist mir egal ob es sich um Demokraten
Republikaner Obama oder Ronny handelt
das ist nicht Teil ihrer Debatte ihre
Debatte findet am Rande statt so dass
die grundlegenden Fragen mit denen die
normalen Menschen konfrontiert sind
nicht Gegenstand demokratischer
überleben sind die Regierung vertritt
nicht das einfach Erfolg obwohl die
Menschen sie wählen geht sie überhaupt
nicht auf Ihre Bedürfnisse eins
in dieser Serie sind wir der Frage
nachgegangen wer Amerika regiert haben
die Geschichte der tiefgreifenden
Konflikte in diesem Land untersucht die
bis zur amerikanischen Revolution
zurückreichen wir haben die Macht des
Militärs der Unternehmen der Medien und
der Wallstreet unter die Lupe genommen
haben gezeigt dass diese mächtigen
Kräfte die Demokratie oft er untergraben
als sie stärken
es ist ein Kampf um die Seele Amerikas
darum wer Amerika regiert er hat diese
tiefen Fragen aufgeworfen die Frage ist
ob ein grundlegender Wandel möglich ist
oder ob special interests und die
Wohlhabenden Amerikaner weiterhin in
einem Land dominieren werden das von
sich behauptet die dynamischste
Demokratie der Welt zu sein der Glaube
an unsere Demokratie hat fast etwas
Religiöses auch wenn es eine Trennung
von Kirche und Staat gibt
vielleicht ist das der Grund warum die
Ansichten die Sie in dieser Reihe gehört
haben vom Establishment von der
Wissenschaft und von der Presse
abgelehnt werden
sie glauben dass nur das Volk die Macht
hat wenn überhaupt aber die
Meinungsführer befassen sich nicht damit
sie konzentrieren sich nicht auf
Interessen sie konzentrieren sich auf
Ideologien auf Persönlichkeiten nicht
auf Institutionen der Gedanke an eine
Macht Elite ist ihnen ein Gräuel
denn wenn die Menschen daran glauben
würden könnte etwas zu Unzufriedenheit
und Dissens führen
im Zeitalter des Internets und des
globalen Fernsehens kann man nicht
verhindern dass die Menschen mit
gegenberichten zu den offiziellen Mythen
konfrontiert werden über diese Themen
lässt sich natürlich streiten aber in
der politischen Berichterstattung werden
andere Sichtweisen auf die Welt meist
nicht diskutiert die üblichen Experten
recyceln konventionelle Weisheiten
sie fragen nicht wer Amerika regiert
die Erde Mitglieder des Kongresses ich
habe das große Privileg und die
besondere Ehre Ihnen den Präsidenten der
Vereinigten Staaten zu präsentieren
[Applaus]